non-minimalists
and i wanted to read these six questions
to ask before
buying to catch up we've got a lot of
new patrons right now
and so i thought we would catch you up
if you don't know about the six
questions asked before buying by the way
we have a version of this
on our website if you go to the
minimalists.com resources
you can download a free wallpaper with
these questions on it
and it doesn't have the expanded version
of the questions but these are
our six questions to ask yourself before
making any new
purchase number one who am i buying this
for the things we own don't tell the
world who we are but sadly they often
communicate who we want to be
when this happens we mistakenly let our
possession shape our identity
we showcase our favorite brands in a
futile effort to signify our own
individuality see this shiny new thing
this is who i am
our logos make us feel unique
just like everybody else
the brands themselves aren't the problem
though we all need some
stuff so we rely on companies to create
the things we need
the problem arises when we feel external
pressure
to acquire as if the new trinkets were a
shortcut to a more
complete life that external pressure
needn't be assigned to consume
if anything it's a sign to pause and ask
who am i buying this for
is that new thing for you or are you
buying it to project an image
for others if it's truly for you and it
makes sense to purchase then
by all means go ahead get it let's not
deprive ourselves of the things that
enhance our lives
but if you're buying things just to
signal a
sort of consumerist equanimity then
you're getting in the way of the freedom
you're attempting to purchase
man anthony uh over at ramsay yes he was
telling us about the i think it was a
gucci bag that he got
anthony o'neil we did so you could
actually check this out anthony o'neil
the table
is the name of his show great podcast um
and yeah
great episode but he was talking about
how he spent
i forget what it was thousands of
dollars on this gucci bag
backpack yes and the whole idea was
he was imagining what people would say
to him and how they would look at him
when he purchased that who am i buying
this for yeah and he uh yeah he
spoiler alert i'm gonna tell you pretty
much the story some cliff notes here
he goes to work he's carrying it anthony
man that's a nice bag man looking cool
walking around people oh where'd you get
that bag at like everyone's doing that
and then he just had this revelation of
like wow like
i literally bought this bag for
attention
and i could put use that money to use
in in such a better way than just
getting people's attention
so he went and he returned it which i
thought was awesome but yeah he the
detailed stories on the podcast it's a
pretty good story
he could have used all six of these
questions for
that purchase yeah by the way i'm on
page 63 right now of love people
use things number two will this add
value to my life
i don't own many things but everything i
own adds value to my life meaning
each of my belongings from my car and
clothes to my furniture and electronics
functions either as a tool or adds
aesthetic value to my life
in other words does it serve a function
or
increase my well-being in a meaningful
way
if not it's not worth buying
back to the gucci bag so let's ask that
question does it serve a function
yes it does is that the best bag
for that function probably not a gucci
bag probably isn't the best bag
well yeah i totally agree um
but there is a function with being
noticed right it's there's a function of
drawing and tension
yes so the question is this is the right
type of function
that you are looking for right and if
you want to seek attention
and you want to do it through a gucci
bag at least admit that right
because then you're being true to
yourself and you're being true to others
and
i'm not saying that you're morally wrong
for doing that you're not but quite
often we justify by saying oh yeah it's
a nice backpack
but really it's like i'm looking for a
shortcut to attract
eyeballs onto me number three can
i afford it this is the third question
to ask
if you have to charge a new purchase to
a credit card
you can't afford it amen if you have to
finance it
you can't afford it amen and if you're
in debt
you can't afford it just because you can
buy something today that doesn't mean
you can actually
afford it if you can't it's better
left on the shelf but what about buying
a house or
going to college surely those are
exceptions right
while they might be different debts and
they're better than say
credit card debt they're still debt it's
been said
for thousands of years that the borrower
is slave to the lender
and so it makes sense to pay off any
debt as quickly as possible
i know this point of view isn't normal
but
normal is what thrust us into our
current
14 trillion dollar mess
we'll address many of the misconceptions
about debt and the relationship with
money
chapter it says here so yeah we do talk
about debt in the book but really the
thing to communicate here is can i
afford it
and and so if i don't have the money to
buy the thing
then i don't buy the thing right that's
the simple way to look at it
number four even if i do have the money
to buy the thing is this the best use of
this money
in other words how else can you use this
money so
the gucci backpack ryan how else could
he have used that money
and when we talked to him about that he
had a dozen answers really quickly
ways he would have rather used the four
thousand dollars whatever
insane amount that he spent on some
backpack
if that was still like oh yeah this is
still the best use of this money for me
okay i'm not gonna judge you for that
sure but you have identified oh and then
you know what
there are maybe a dozen other ways i'd
rather spend this money
or even if there's one other way you'd
rather spend this money
then it's not the best use of the money
in other words how else can you use this
money what are the alternatives
the songwriter andy davis sings a line
in his song
good life that succinctly captures our
culture's
misappropriation of finances ryan you
want to sing this line for us
no i'm not going to sing it it's a great
line though
uh yeah we struggle to pay rent because
jeans are expensive
i mean what's he saying yeah he's like
yeah you know what my priorities are
wrong
but i gotta look good in them jeans yes
yeah and and that's what we do we're
struggling to pay
rent not because we're struggling to pay
rent but because we are allocating the
money in these places that don't
align with the person we want to be
question number five
from love people use things what's the
actual cost
as discussed in the introduction chapter
the true cost of a thing goes well
beyond its price tag
in business they call this full cost
accounting
but let's call it what it really is
these are the actual costs of owning all
the things we think we need
when it comes to the items we own we
must consider the
storage costs maintenance costs and
psychological costs
when we add it all up we're able to
understand
the true cost and often we realize
we can't afford it even if we can afford
the upfront cost and finally number six
would the best version of me buy this
and i really think that's what anthony
was struggling with with that backpack
this isn't the best version of me yeah
this is the attention seeking version of
me it's a fabricated version
in attention he knows that attention is
a byproduct
of doing something meaningful with his
work with his creativity with his show
whatever it might be that gets him the
attention he gives a talk in front of
all these college students or high
school students
that's a different type of attention
that's earned attention
there is no shortcut there are only
direct paths right
a few years ago my friend leslie stood
in her local grocer's checkout line
fumbling with her wallet's zipper
preparing to make an impulse purchase
but then suspended in queue she was
given
time to question the thing in her hand
she pondered the item carefully and
asked herself a question
what would joshua do that is if i were
in her shoes
would i make this purchase no she
thought
and promptly returned the item to the
shelf
when she told me about her experience
she joked that she wanted to buy
one of those wwjd bracelets to help her
avoid
compulsive consumption going forward i
laughed
but then realized that i too could
benefit from making more frequent use
of this question and so could others to
be clear
i don't want you to walk around asking
yourself what would joshua do
please don't rather it's a rhetorical
question
what would the best version of you
do in this situation if he or she
wouldn't buy it
then you know what to do pausing to
consider
each new purchase with these six
questions
seems like a hassle at first but in time
it's a habit that will reward you and
your family with less clutter around the
house
and more money to spend on what's
important to you
after all the easiest way to de-clutter
your life is to avoid
bringing it home in the first place
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today your support keeps
our podcast and youtube channel
one hundred percent advertisement free